let's talk about the number one food
that has the most vitamin K2 but I want
to just cover a little bit of history on
vitamin K2 now you see this book right
here is called nutrition and physical
degeneration by Dr Weston Price okay he
was a dentist but he did a lot of
research back in the 30s and the 40s and
he visited these remote cultures that
ate very very healthy foods and he was
trying to identify what was it about
their diet that generated such amazing
teeth as compared to nowadays everyone
needs braces you know we have our wisdom
teeth pulled because there's not enough
space in her skull the teeth are
overcrowded a lot of problems with
overbite underbite not to mention my
teeth I pretty much had cavities in
every single tooth in my skull so
Western price looked at calcium he
looked at the fat soluble vitamins maybe
at first he thought it was vitamin D or
vitamin A or vitamin E but at the time
vitamin K2 wasn't identified side and so
it was really interesting that he had a
term for it called activator X it's kind
of like the X Factor just something in
addition to these regular fat soluble
vitamins that is creating really good
teeth like really good bones good bone
structure and overall good health he
just didn't know about vitamin K2
because it wasn't discovered yet and so
he looked at cultures in the Swiss Alps
and he found that they ate a lot of
grass-fed butter and cheese and really
really natural things and so he
identified their teeth being just like
really really good fast forward we know
now it's vitamin K2
does vitamin K1 that's all about
clotting and then there's vitamin K2
which is all about calcium
Transportation vitamin K2 works with
vitamin D okay now vitamin D helps a
person absorb calcium in the intestines
by a factor of 20 times if someone
doesn't have enough vitamin D calcium
really won't be absorbed in the blood
too well
and so vitamin D is all about raising
calcium in the blood but vitamin K2
takes it to the next level it takes the
calcium from the blood and it pushes
into the bone and so the way it does
this is it activates certain proteins
and another thing that's really
interesting about vitamin K2 it uses a
transport system called LDL that
so-called bad cholesterol that
everyone's trying to avoid well it takes
a ride in LDL through the body and then
it ends up in your bones so it makes
your bones really really solid it helps
certain parts of your teeth become very
very strong
it keeps calcium from building up in the
arteries it prevents vascular
calcification it also prevents calcium
from ending up in your cartilage or in
your joints as an arthritis things like
that so it's all about calcium
Transportation it activates a very
important cell called the beta cell in
your pancreas which makes insulin more
sensitive so if a person has insulin
resistance which the majority of the
population has it can really help
someone's blood sugar by improving
insulin resistance because now it's
going to make insulin more sensitive
then your body can make less insulin it
helps generate more ATP or energy in the
muscle cell you're going to have a lot
more energy
to do exercise it also is involved in
supporting the cells that make
testosterone it also works on the brain
it improves spatial learning as well as
memory which is pretty cool and like I
said before it also inhibits this
calcium buildup in the arteries and in
the joints so you can see it's a very
very important vitamin and we need to
have it in our diet unfortunately
there's no requirements or rdas for K2
yet even though we need it now the
majority of vitamin K2 comes from
bacteria and so when a cow eats grass
that is loaded with vitamin K1 that
vitamin K1 changes into Vitamin K2 with
the help of bacteria vitamin K1 and
vitamin K2 are fat soluble vitamins so
it is stored in fat so if someone goes
low fat or they're on medications that
block cholesterol for example example
they may not get enough vitamin K2 at
least the microbes in your own gut do
make
some of the K2 that you have in your
body okay and that's made from vitamin
K1 so there's a little conversion going
on in your gut and as a side note E coli
is one of the bacteria that has this
ability to help you make k2 and I'm not
talking about the pathogenic version I'm
talking about the version that is fairly
friendly in your body it actually makes
certain B vitamins and it also makes
vitamin K2 from vitamin K1 which is
interesting the number one food that has
the most vitamin K2 is cheese there is
one other food that has more vitamin K2
but most people are not going to consume
it so I didn't want to even mention that
cheese is number two but I'm just going
to put it number one because most people
will consume cheese the number one
product is really NATO which is a
fermented soybean which if you ever
tasted it you probably would not like it
too much it's kind of an acquired taste
it's kind of like my dad lacking
Limburger cheese right which basically
has a very unique flavor which we all
couldn't stand growing up but recently I
tasted some of it and actually now I
kind of like it it does not taste like
it smells but as far as the abundance of
K2
cheese is at the very top of the list
mainly it's the hard cheeses
but it's also in the soft cheeses
but out of all of the hard cheeses and
the soft cheeses there's one cheese that
it ranks number one and that is called
the monster cheese okay which is grown
in the mountains of France where they
create this cheese with raw milk not the
pasteurized milk that they use in the
U.S now it is true that vitamin K2 Will
Survive some of the pasteurization the
heating of the cheese but it also kills
off the microbes right that are making
the K2 so you're always going to find
more vitamin K2 in things that are more
raw especially when we get into cheese
there's all sorts of versions of vitamin
K2 right there's this kind of like these
subset versions of vitamin K2 you have
like the MK4 mk7
Etc but in cheese you have
MK4 MK5 you have MK6 mk7 mk8 and also
MK9 so you have a huge variety of
different versions of this vitamin K2 as
compared to some other foods that may
only have one version like maybe MK4 or
mk7 but if you can find some raw cheese
that would always be better usually
European cheese high quality hard
cheeses are going to have a little bit
more soft cheeses will have a little bit
less but you're still going to get a
good amount of vitamin K2 in cheese now
some people are going to say well wow I
thought this saturated fat and the
cheese was bad right it's going to
create heart problems and now I'm
confused because vitamin K2 removes the
calcium out of the arteries and that
also helps prevent heart disease so
what's more important removing the
calcium from the arteries or the
cholesterol that's building up from all
the Scotty Foods well just to clear the
confusion I'm going to put some links
down below of some clinical trials and I
think you'll find interesting
completely refuting this data that
saturated fat will make you die earlier
or increase your risk for heart attacks
or other problems there's absolutely no
evidence to show that saturated fat is
going to worsen your health or cause
diabetes unfortunately there's
recommendations that we should increase
our unsaturated fats the omega-6 to
replace the saturated fats is bad
information now I just have to say
something about those recommendations
the governmental recommendations first
of all anything related to health that's
recommended by the government
um might not be true I mean if you think
about who is the government is there one
person is there a group is there a panel
are these recommendations slightly
biased from various groups that can have
influence over these policies the answer
is a big fat yes there's definitely a
revolving door between industry and
government kind of goes back and forth
so anything recommended relating to
health from the government take it with
a grain of salt so we have cheese a
really good source of vitamin K2 we also
have grass-fed butter butter that is
made from cows that ate grains have very
little vitamin K2 why is that because
grains don't have a lot of K1 grass has
a lot of K1 and that K1 gets converted
into the K2 so it's grass-fed it's grass
finished or another way to say that is
100 grass-fed that's what you want to
consume as far as the butter and other
Foods if you want to get more K2 the
cool thing about butter is that butter
has it's like great amounts of vitamin A
vitamin E it has vitamin D and it has
vitamin K2 it's really good for someone
that has osteoporosis or osteopenia or
osteomalacia or even rickets these are
all problems with the bone and then you
have things like Goose liver duck liver
duck fat eel yes eel is loaded with
vitamin K2 beef liver or lamb liver
liver has vitamin K2 ground beef
grass-fed hot dogs I'm not talking about
the process you know hot dogs that you
would get when you go to a ball game or
something like that I'm talking about
like high quality grass-fed no sugar
added clean hot dogs has vitamin K2
bacon I'm not talking about the
commercial regular bacon I'm talking
about a higher quality bacon has K2 in
fact out of all the meats pork has the
most vitamin K2 which is interesting and
then you also have like sauerkraut it's
a fermented product it has vitamin K2
with the help of the bacteria and also
cod liver oil is another great thing
especially for children growing up a
woman who is lactating
a child who's growing up should have on
a regular basis high quality cheese
unless there's some allergy and high
quality butter and cod liver oil and not
only will that help them avoid getting
braces but it's going to improve their
entire health and if you're taking
vitamin D always make sure you take
vitamin K2 with it because they work
hand in hand sometimes people are
concerned with the toxicity of vitamin D
but if you take vitamin K2 okay and
magnesium you can greatly offset the
toxicity that could potentially occur if
you're taking massive amounts for many
many many months now since you're on the
topic of vitamin K2 there's a lot more
to know about it you should check out
this video that I did that has quite a
few views I'll put it up right here